allora partiamo subito con l'argomento
principale preveduto e ciao a tutti come
potete aver capito ben dal titolo se
siete delle persone così sveglie per le
ro di kabul
io adoro giocare tabù per questo che
farò una scenetta solo per voi
e spiace per le donne perché ci saranno
due ragazze una ceretta che avranno una
barba
però mi pesa altamente il mio caro amico
jack e quindi non mi andava di allora tu
stai con me mentre io sto con un ok a
questo punto un tool prima di iniziare
ci stanno sempre quasi in tutti i giochi
25 seguiti tarde nei giochi da tavolo
quelli dove detenuto sarebbe invece
bella altri tipi di abilità caffè e lo
sborone all'inizio cioè tende vi può
tirare quindi una scelta tipo mamma mia
cosa non abbiamo fatto l'altra volta
perche abbiamo proprio fatto rimpiangere
gli assenti e calcola che a un certo
punto abbiamo fatto tipo 7 caselle di
fila cioè una cosa assurda
cioè siamo troppo forti vai mitica e si
inizia il gioco
dopo questa pantomima assurda più
agguerriti che mai si mangia a colazione
cereali latte sonorità thing fette
biscottate fi e vice all
il mio sogno erotico fratello un cuscino
cucina una una cosa una cosa che l'odio
attaccare la toppa dei cani per strada
ancora peggio mangiarsela infinito
mangiare così lo si passa tra i denti
mi viene in mente una cosa volgare o
caso è in questo mondo inizia il gioco
il vero che più va avanti e più
incomincia a trovare maniera ancora più
assurde per far capire
parola e diciamo che molte volte molte
volte quello che scegli non è del tutto
corretto
che fretta c'era maledetta primavera
parrucca fa torino
ma cosa non si fa per vincere un gioco
anche se tuttavia gli avversari pure se
non si conoscono perché sono 21 si mette
con l'amichetto che conosce poi lascia
agli articoli tini da soli al trovarsi
invece no va a finire che a volte
persone gli esterni pur non conoscendosi
fa finiscono per essere dei mostri di
bravura che l'ha fatta sentire un idiota
perché due tipo da cinque anni che il
gioco 5 anche giochi ogni giorno se ti
senza fine un po un sinonimo di vaccini
in ambito bellico povero l'albero della
cromia susino allo king 2 mag con ben
stiller compound da yaya touré in lingua
maya follicolare mangiarla camposanto no
caposaldo buy
esatto un'altra cosa [ __ ] sono le figure
di merda che fai
nel senso quando ti tiri proprio gli
sfondoni è la cosa peggiore quando ci
azzecchi ciò che sono abbastanza subito
però alla fine finisce presse tipo così
allora striscia sull'addome ventriloquo
bravo fi ragazzi no sì il ventriloqui
sono quelli con impazzì mi vuoi bene lo
è triste che siete riusciti a indovinare
in questo modo per concludere così c'è
poco da fare se volete giochiamo tutti
facciamo tv organizzando un partito
notte
ci buttiamo dai vi faccio vedere che
abilita alto e quelli l'abbraccio con
rock dei pezzi proprio mai visti
perrotta è grande appello guarda riesco
a fatica a immaginare come però dai
no no no